tu peux n'a pas l'équipe ou pas je
connais tout le monde et je passe des
vannes sur tout le monde là c'est ça
l'histoire
ouais ouais ben vas-y moi je crois que
j'avais neuf soir tranquille quand m ghz
comme la chanson de maître gims et au
bond vas-y voiture games et joey starr
non non c'est bon merci si c'est bon pas
là alors oui c'est qu'il dit je suis
d'accord
julien combes et patrick à dire sur lui
allez y lâchez les deux ans sur les
jours
alors maintenant j'ai été très touchée
bref je sais c'est vrai non mais c'est
vrai vous avez vu ce qui se passe
c'était très beau ce qu'ils avaient
montré je veux dire étoile jean marc
satta touché aussi way
ah ouais vraiment tu as déjà vu un ours
de près toi non et toi oui je me suis
déjà vu tout lu dans la glace
y'a géraldine maillet qui aime bien tu
aimes bien un jeu tourniquet les
philosophes moi je l'aïe a orienté sa
l'ex-site jean-marc moi il est pas mal
d'ailleurs j'ai un cadeau pour jean-marc
l'appeler pour lui enfin c'est pas toi
tu en avais pas fait en vain on attend
ça va changer ton calendrier resserré
jeff pas d'un club calendrier 2018 c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau offert on regarde
les photos regarde janvier et avec des
meufs frères février avec des meufs à
l'arrêt toujours tiger woods avec des
basses et boyet calendrier jack pas
d'acord 2010 d'ailleurs je serai un
petit a signalé ce pas pour revenir sur
les hausses mais il ya un euro reversé à
30 millions d'amis alors oui alors comme
jean marc aymes faire l'amour est un
maître amoureux des livres absolument
extraordinaire pour lui c'est les plus
belles histoires d'amour racontée par
nicolas rey qu'on adore et cartons alors
que larry ouais donc évidemment il ya
les affaires il a beaucoup de talent
vraiment magnifique alors il ya
évidemment signoret montant il ya eu ni
winehouse et pete doherty ya tous les
amours qui ont un peu traversé l'esprit
la bataille et fontaine
habite au lard et adore ça alors ça
c'est pour qui ce pour moi pour jeff
annoncé pour tfc pour jean marc marc
bonjour bâton c'est à dire bon format
voilà bah jean marie coup jean michel
maire
non monsieur le maire tu le connais
govou si on regarde le livre c'est une
bibliothèque qui suivent partout ce
qu'ils n' moi oui tu prends tu te tapes
on chez toi nicolas rey les plus belles
histoires je vais l'offrir ce truc my
hands off temps son jockey mon pote le
dire je prends un petit pénis grâce si
time of pas appel annabi ou tadeusz
ouais c'est que c'est la reine avoir dit
on pas à les lire mais toutes tes
repères webb avait aussi tout est refait
surtout les cheveux je connais très bien
jean michel marmin clinique du poil et
tu sais qui pourrait donner des conseils
sur les mots clés ouais bah prends ça
comme un lieu donné mais calme chantal
biya n'a peut-être de s'épiler un peu ce
que là c'est la mode plus tellement
d'où la sacu cei amour mais tellement
drôle que je pense que déjà le plus gros
est fait avec les filles prescillia il
est tellement drôle qu avec les filles
je pense que c'est gagné d'avancé et
jean miché mais reçoit des demeures il
nous a fait une phrase là qu'on aurait
pu voir sur france 3 à 16 heures en
écoute les clippers vas-y been and i
want is you actelis non gênant maxime
cas des couleurs de noël où il sera
sorti à la guerre le rebond d'hier est
surtout un marron glacé à quoi mais
c'est vrai que lors du raid n'avait pas
les miens je comprends rien montré quand
il était jeune il prend comme nous je te
dirai a lui aussi cherché de ma fille il
était qu'il était sur kelly un moment
projet sur le programme sur le projet
d'accord était sur kelly après l'été sur
haga est en fait il est sûr qu'il lui
personne je n'ai aucune excuse vient pas
aux autres si vous êtes maintenant voilà
neuf ans calme-toi et thomas mais comme
si je calme-toi offriront à bas la junte
à trucs à dire sur ba jin rêve ait
appris tout en mosaïque tout à l'heure
dans les coulisses alors finalement je
vous dois dû balle ouais bah je vais
vous le dire je vous fait crédit
illimité d'accord merci bas ça me fait
ça me fait ça me fait extrêmement vous
l'avait bien dit jamais assez des vrais
amis quand et là j'ai mis la barre haut
niveau on se connaît depuis longtemps
avec isabelle c'est vrai ouais mais
dynamique et non pas vous connaissez on
s'est rencontré il ya longtemps j'ai
fait mes premières san devant ils
avaient 1982 oui et quarante deux ans
dans un paysage c'est vrai mais oui j'ai
présidé à ses débuts en partie ah ouais
quand même
mais pourquoi partie des gens qui ont
cru à regagner des concours grâce à
isabelle non un jury où j'étais à wells
avec elle alors c'est plein de comics
ray dans le mur
maryvonne de theix voilà une mésaventure
sur ce même plateau 1 voilà mais ça va
s'arranger on pense
ouais à côté c'est yannick et l'ambiance
ah ouais
et puis à côté sétois d'un côté je
regarde 1 télé quoi
ouais c'est parce que faute à le voir en
vrai héros c'est le gars non avec el
hadj baba 60 60
ouais mais bon t'as quel âge tu as vu
mon âge je me dis pas mais on s'en fout
il a 60 ans bernard montiel découverte
anniversaire 10 9 avril chez 1h57 donc
ça fait 60 ans donc non vous serez vaut
60 ans et non 62 n'a pas été invitée
vous avez fait désormais vous sûrement à
saint barth d'ailleurs away à johnny si
plaisant mais ouais mais nous on est
convaincu qu'on n'était pas invité ça
fait loin il y avait qui devint vite et
surtout ses vraies personnes gentilles
et culture invités à votre anniversaire
on le fout dans la mer et des amis de
différentes régions des amis merci à
mieux vivre il est avec nous
on a découvert sur eux arrête de arrête
avec tes clichés sur passe pas que du
tout et j'adore qu'ils aient alors monde
adore effet absolument oui yahya yahya
un peu tôt mais il ya beaucoup de succès
j'adore zoukeur diouf
mais je crois pour pouvoir
alors aujourd'hui non
c'est dur ça va pas lui salaire je lui
dis tous les jours moi non plus parti se
cacher ses liquidités
mais il faut que tu calmes jean marc
alunno marque cerveau génial methot à
milliane est d'accord il ya jean luc
lemoine jean libon levage de ta connerie
je me retrouvais dans les cas peut-être
t'as pas envie de savoir si on devrait
existe pas